how old were you when you did Smallville
everything I'm gonna say I'm always off
a little bit my mom would be like Ryan
that's not even true uh so let's say I
think I was 16 the first time the first
season 16 are you sure you were that old
15 I mean also I I looked like you
looked young you were like me a late
bloomer yes so that's another thing that
was probably throwing you too Smallville
was the first like it changed my life in
the sense of that was I had been acting
when I was younger and Smallville was
the first time that I saw adults doing
it for a living like it clicked in my
head I was like wait yeah I remember you
guys um especially the second season you
guys were going through like talking to
each other about contract negotiations I
remember you remember that a little bit
yeah and I remember thinking like wow
that'd be so cool one day if I could do
that
um but the first one for sure I was like
wait you guys do this for a living like
you don't do anything like you didn't
this is what you do you know and you
guys like yeah